any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everyone to a new
episode of the into the impossible
podcast
featuring
myself
brian keating
and uh and someone i've known for over a
year and i've been trying so desperately
to get on the podcast because she shares
so many interests uh with me she's uh
she's got the three ps she's got my
interest in poetry
physics and she's a pilot and we're
going to talk about all those things
today and what makes her tick it's
joanne roberts but we're going to call
her paradigm a fourth p
in the universe and that goes along with
polarization which is how i came to meet
her through the simon's observatory uh
program that she participated in last
summer joanne how are you doing welcome
to the west coast thank you i'm happy to
be here i love california i'm doing
quite well
uh not so great with the wildfire season
but you know hoping it gets better as
the years come let me read paradigms
biography she's a native of the universe
paradigm joanne roberts uh the jovian
that i want to get into as well how many
nicknames can we get into uh she was
born and raised in chicago she's a poet
an mc
musician and producer i just had on
stephon alexander who was the president
of the national society of black
physicist is still and his book fear for
black universe was
endorsed by
none other than chuck d a public enemy
and your book is endorsed by none other
than cornell west is that sister joanne
will cause trouble in the corporate
world
she knows and speaks the truth uh so she
obtained a bachelor's of science in
engineering physics with a philosophy
minor at chicago state university and
she earned her private pilot license at
siu southern illinois uh carbondale and
she's now at astrophysics in the uc
system so we're in the same university
so paradigm we always start off
every author that comes on the show has
to confront the advice that you're given
to never judge a book by its cover but i
want to ask you
uh since since a lot of my listenership
may not know about you
how did you get the name of this
wonderful new uh book of poems uh called
continuum and uh and what came how did
you come up with the cover art or the
cover design what motivated you to do
those two things well uh first i'll talk
a little bit about the cover
i love astronomy and astrophysics
and that is one of my favorite photos it
was the deep space photo taken by the
hubble telescope
so i thought that that would be a good
reference to the title
continuum
in the sense of
it being something that is ongoing
and that
you know that there are
many layers and levels
to our existence and to us
so i i just figured that would be
you know a good reflection of where i
was going with the poetry but also a
good reflection of my love for
the wonders of the universe
so
and it is a delightful collection um and
uh and i found it you know really
refreshing because you know there is
that kind of a notion i don't know if
you've ever heard it um paul dirac who
is one of the founders of quantum theory
uh he was no fan of poetry
and he used to say stuff that i would
quote in my um
in my uh poetry uh poet poetry for
physicist class which i taught with
professor ray armentrout who won the
pulitzer prize from president obama back
in 2011 i think um she and i co-taught a
class and i said i always wanted to
teach you know you always hear about um
you know physics for poets but we wanted
to do poetry for physicists and i
started off that class my lecture we
shared it together with dirac's quote he
said and i quote in science one tries to
tell people
in such a way as to be understood by
everyone something that no one ever knew
before but in the case of poetry it's
the exact opposite in other words it's
poetry is like intentionally confu how
do you react to this to this dirac's
quote this disparagement of poetry is
that warranted
just so i'm clear he's arguing that
poetry is intentionally confusing
correct
uh
i feel that poetry is a reflection of
life
so if the poetry is confusing then it's
just
maneuvering through the existence of
our confusing lives
which could be very confusing at times
so i mean i just write through my life
experiences
um there are many things in life that
have confused me that i've gotten
clarity
um by writing about it
so
i guess that would be my take on that i
mean
life is a little confusing you know it's
a little confusing for everyone
we reach points in our lives where we're
confused by things or confused about
which way to turn i feel that poetry
helps me to figure all of that out so
i would slightly disagree i would only
agree that poetry can be reflective of
life's confusion
but i think it can be a tool to help us
get through that confusion
yeah i i can't i can't disagree with
that i think you know dirac by the way
his own brother-in-law said that paul
never uses two words when zero will do
but i actually think he was a deeply
closeted uh poet because in his work he
made use of fundamentals of verse of
economy of parsimony of this notion of
symmetry and structure now i think
poetry has a lot to teach physicists and
i think physicists have a lot to teach
poets what do you think about those they
inter intermingling of the two
disciplines that you engage in
well uh
i was asked a question before um how do
you bridge
the expressive arts with the sciences
and my answer to that was well i am the
bridge
so
the way that i maneuver through this
is to
just trust
that
everything i'm about as a poet and
everything i'm about as a physicist
will always be in balance and even
through the contradictions there are
still
compliments
right they still complement each other
in a lot of different ways and i always
find ways to bring poetry into
my
physics and i always find ways to bring
physics into my poetry so it's just very
natural for me i don't even really think
about it to be honest it's just
reflective of my love for the two fields
and do you attribute that to
natural
gift hard work
struggle that you've had in other words
why aren't more of our physics
colleagues
more conversant with the with the
expressive arts
uh
i think they don't know that they're
artists and deep down they really are
um
that's the way that i look at that um
i spent some years teaching
high school students how to rap how to
write poetry about stage etiquette
recording
self-reflection
you know
using art as a therapeutic tool
and what i found is that
a lot of the students that would come to
me in the beginning and say hey
i'm not doing this i can't rap i can't
write poetry i can't even perform like
and it gives me a lot of gratification
um by the time i'm done with them and
we're rounding up the program
um they're rapping they're writing
poetry they're performing in slams
winning slams they're making songs
making videos
um
and this all stemmed from them just not
knowing that there is an artist within
them so i would apply that same thing to
scientists and i know that
there can be a lot of pushback with that
but i feel that that's part of the
reason that steam is becoming more
prevalent as we maneuver through the
arts and sciences as well um so
a lot of my research and a lot of my
focus will be in steam which is you know
the stem plus the arts
um
i think that's the the best way that i
can answer that because
i truly believe that everyone is
an artist deep down in some way
yeah
yeah and it sort of gets taken out of
them and i feel everyone's a scientist
or at least all kids start off as
scientists they're curious they're
playful they're imaginative they're
inquisitive then they don't play well
with others they're selfish they're
jealous you know all the bad traits of
scientists are all the good traits of
scientists there's no such thing as a
single-edged sword and you know what i'm
trying to develop in in my students
uh is an appreciation for what you know
uh people call the the the two cultures
and but make it a third culture
that the arts are to be integrated and i
think the best uh physicists are artists
in a way and it may be orators it may be
speakers and and uh your
victoriousness in in in slams talk about
slams talk about freestyle
how do those two things like square that
circle to me because i think you know
there's an old jerry seinfeld joke and
he says
more people are scared of public
speaking than of death so you'd rather
be in the coffin
than delivering the eulogy
um so that's that's the way most people
are how did you did you have an uh you
know and an obstacle to that path or did
it always come natural to you the slams
the the freestyle how how did that
integrate into your into your persona
well first i want to say i like your
emphasis on
how you believe that everyone is a
scientist deep down
because i can see a lot of parallels
with what you were saying about the
imagination and
the creativity and things like that
never looked at it that way so
appreciate that um as far as how i've
uh
moved through
[Music]
public performance and public speaking
uh
i still experience stage fright believe
it or not
um
i've learned to appreciate it over time
um and that's something that i've
instilled in my students like
hey look stage fright isn't something
that's just gonna miraculously disappear
someday i mean even beyonce who is
probably one of the greatest performers
of all time and of our generation
has admitted to experiencing stage
fright
still to this day
it's very normal um and what i do is i
just
allow it to give me that adrenaline that
i need
and it reminds me that i care about what
i'm doing i care about what i'm saying
right
um
and it
helps me to really give my all when i'm
on stage and really just trust in my art
and trust in the message
and trust that people will be able to
receive it and it always goes well right
when i get off the stage i'm always like
i should have said that differently or i
messed up that word or i stuttered here
or all just because i stuttered this one
word now the entire performance is is
mute right
but um the kind of feedback that i get
lets me know that people don't even pay
attention to the things that we pay
attention to we're our own worst critics
you know
so it's it's just something that i've
grown through
um appreciating that stage fright does
not go away but
you know seeing it as a tool that i can
utilize
to really give my all and remind me that
i care about what i'm doing and it also
keeps me humble
when we think about you know kind of
these these notions of of what we're
good at what we're not good at people
what are people gonna think about me i'm
reminded of two different biases that
people have
one is the imposter syndrome like i'm
not good enough i'm not strong enough
whatever i'm not meant to be here i'm
inadequate
and then another one is the spotlight
effect that you were just talking about
like oh like literally you feel like
there's a spotlight on you 24 7. and the
truth is nobody cares about you i'm not
i don't mean you personally but like
people you know who most people care
about themselves right
so most people are 100 focused on
themselves and okay every now and then
they might be snarky or something else
but the doing of it the attempting of a
great thing um is in itself kind of a
character you know reformation that i
think is is missing in most of my
undergraduate students you know i meet
them and they're they might say to me oh
it's hard like i can't do that professor
keating like
i can't speak in front of people uh i
couldn't do like freestyle uh some of my
students are foreign students uh it's
really i say oh yeah you know i guess i
guess you were born knowing uh i guess
you were born knowing advanced quantum
mechanics like i i guess you were just
like really good at lagrangian dynamic
like you were born no you had to work at
it and right nothing worth having uh
comes for free and i think what i think
my audience would be really interested
in is kind of hearing your your
so-called heroine's journey like how you
got here the world line that you took
were there any you know like
moments in time that were critical
points as we say in thermodynamics were
there were there phase transitions um
because the name paradigm really evokes
something central in science and i'm
curious if you can take us up was there
a paradigm shift where you became the
identity that you are now uh and all
it's in all its wonderful facets um was
it slow was it punctuated equilibrium
how did you get talk us through your
world line from chicago to davis and
into the universe
oh man uh how much time do you have
um
well first i want to say that as an
artist um i'll just elaborate on that a
little bit uh the first time i ever
performed
in public was at siu carbondale when i
was training to be a pilot
and i had joined this organization
called um
the
what is it
underground arts
and it's just a student organization on
campus for students that were
different variations of artists and they
would put on open mics and things like
that and i performed a piece that i had
written
and i was so overwhelmed uh that i
stopped mid-piece because i just had to
re-gather myself and catch my breath
um
i kept forgetting my next lines i mean
it to me it was like just a horrible
performance
but the kind of uh
reception
uh you know the kind of feedback that i
got when i was finished let me know that
i
had something going for myself
right um and it wasn't until i moved to
new york
because i've done a lot of traveling i
lived in new york for a few years
where i began to perform more
and i began to realize that i truly had
some sort of gift for
the art of words
and i decided to dive into it further
and uh
published my first book in 2012
and that was something i never thought
i would see i didn't even know how to do
that
but i found someone who was able to help
me with it
coming years later i published two more
books
up until now we have continuum which is
a combination of those first three books
with some of my latest poetry i just
combined it all into a collection or an
anthology of sorts
but um
you know my my journey as an artist has
been
just believing in myself and the name
paradigm was given to me
um
i don't remember who gave it to me but i
know that when they it was 2007 or 2006
i believe they were just like you're a
paradigm and i was like oh
i think that's my name and it just stuck
um
even with that name you know where it's
defined as something that serves as a
pattern or a model it's really allowed
me to really
see my place
as an artist in society in the ways in
which we contribute
um
not sure have you seen uh the dead poet
society with robin williams
i don't what is it
um okay
any relations
okay um
but i mean that one scene where he was
in the class breaking down to the
students you know
engineering law you know medicine these
are noble pursuits but poetry you know
the the things that artists contribute
to life you know that that is really
what creates that balance between
the creatives and the ones that
contribute to pushing us forward
technologically you know um and i really
appreciated him saying that so much that
i featured it on one of my spoken word
albums
um
but
that's kind of led up to where i am now
where i'm pursuing a phd in physics
and you know as an artist
i feel like it's always been polarized i
feel like there's just been this
dichotomy of
science
versus the arts you can't be both you
have to choose one or the other right
and
that's the kind of household i grew up
in as well you know i had the kind of
father that was like you know if you
want to play guitar i mean that's that's
fine but you're not going to get
anywhere with that you know this is the
real world you have to work you have to
make money you have to go to school for
something you have to do something
that's lucrative
you know um and i believe that for a
long time but i think in recent years i
just got to a point where
i was just
i just decided i don't want to choose
between one or the other anymore i'm
going to create a bridge
be a bridge and have the balance of
these two beautiful
uh
fields in my life
and that is how i got here today where i
am in davis getting ready to start grad
school which i never thought i would be
doing um for
astrophysics at that you know um as much
as i love this field i there was a time
i didn't think i was smart enough to
even
finish a an undergrad degree
in stem you know but here i am and i'm
very happy about it and i'm happy to be
bringing
my artistic endeavors along with me so
um
uh it's truly truly inspirational now
talk about yourself as an aviator as a
pilot
um
i i started i thought aviation
uh at a you know immature age or a
younger age than most people in in
graduate school you did it you know even
even younger and earlier uh talk about
that what is aviation um how does that
tie into your persona who you are uh
your identity because i've heard it said
by i don't know are you familiar with uh
john and martha king the king schools uh
they do like videos on flight training
and stuff like that
i'm not a familiar with that yeah they
do they're actually here in san diego
and i met him once um uh the husband
john and he said like being a pilot is
an identity even if you stop flying you
never fly again you're always a pilot
for the rest of your life all those who
have slipped the surly bonds of earth
have become pilots and that's part of
who you are talk about what does
aviation mean to you john uh
the first time i flew solo i mean that's
something you never forget right
because that that entire time i
with flight training with my instructor
in the seat next to me
uh you really notice the weight
difference when you take off by yourself
so i noticed that first first hand um
but
i mean ever since i was about six years
old i knew i wanted to be
an astronaut
engineer
something of that nature by the time i
was in high school
i brought that down a few hundred
thousand
feet to being a pilot
but
i mean
i was afraid to fly
at first you know i was terrified of
flying i was convinced the first time
that i got on an airplane that that was
going to be the end of me
i was 11 years old um i embarrassed my
sister
you know we were flying down to houston
to visit my grandparents from chicago
and it was my first time flying i think
this was in about 96 or 97
so to make matters worse it was just me
and my sister i didn't have the comfort
of my parents on the plane with me or
anything like that and i remember just
bawling like just being a hysterical
mess
because i was just convinced like this
plane is going down like there's no way
we're making it to houston safely
um but once i experienced what it felt
like to take off and once we actually
did make it to houston
um and we landed
there was a slight fascination that grew
from that
um so out of that fear came
intrigue
and that is how i
became interested in aviation um
and once i learned how to fly
and i learned how airplanes work
and i felt what it feels like to be in
the cockpit to be in control
to be pilot in command
it was life-changing i'm no longer
afraid to fly
needless to say um
usually when i do fly i'm just going
through my head everything the pilots
are doing as we're taking off
um everything they're doing as we're
landing you know things like that um
and i just love planes now just you know
it's
uh space shuttles planes you name it
anything with wings i love it
and
it it's it's just a funny story to tell
because it it just goes back to me just
being terrified and thinking that i was
going to die the first time i flew
um i want to read a palmer if you could
read it well you don't have a your book
is sold out uh i got my copy uh
delivered to courtesy of you but i also
got the
kindle version
online and everybody should do that i'll
put a link in the show notes um i love
this poem black aviator
yeah could you please do me the honor of
reading that wonderful poem black
aviator one page 146 in the
uh hard copy and the paperback if you're
playing along at home
absolutely
so
this uh poem just to give a little
background it gives a little more um
insight into my journey into aviation
and my background growing up on the
south side of chicago
where there aren't many pilots
you know um
but i was that kid that was you know six
years old um
infatuated with the universe infatuated
with space and uh
you know
that's how this came to be so i'll just
get into the
piece on the city's south side there is
only one way
monday through sunday you must be weary
of gun play
where some lack an education but dream
to make it out someday
where you don't see blacks in aviation
still i chose life on the runway
every time i'd board a plane my kind was
not in the captain's seat and because of
that i figured there were other things
i'd have to be
but when i looked into our history i
questioned all i was made to believe i
read up on bessie coleman and realized
there is nothing i can achieve
i felt so weightless and free the first
time i ever flew solo it was like the
sky was made just for me and god gave me
a deal on the low low
i'm paving roads for
that i'm paving roads for the no names
with payback and such incentives spent
all my parents money with no shame
because you know flight training is
expensive but no matter how hollow my
means i pursued and followed my dreams
finding light in the darkness i come
from and sharing it with other chicago
teams
today i go full throttle rotate before
the runways finish
with cloud 9 at my wing tips i now know
the sky truly has no limit
so on the south side of chicago where
many feel they have no options
trailblazers emerge from struggle and
i'm here a black woman in the cockpit
that's that piece
i love that poem it's always interesting
and you know joanne because we
we talked earlier you know we're trying
to coordinate this uh interview for
months now with our hectic schedules and
your move to become a grad student and
then we decided we would do it on the
day between our two birthdays
mine september 9th and your september
11th
i want to ask you about september 11 as
a pilot
as as an aviator
how did that day affect you
uh
let's see that was my
hoping no one does the math here
but that was my 15th birthday in in
2001.
um
it was a rough day for me it was uh
you know i think everyone remembers
where they were what they were doing uh
when they started hearing the news
reports if you weren't in new york city
already
um
i was in chicago i was in high school i
was a
i was turning 15 so i was a sophomore
i was in my spanish class that morning
and um i remember just having an eerie
feeling you know just i'm excited about
my birthday and everything but you know
um later on i read about this some years
later that it was kind of a collective
conscious
kind of a feeling that was felt globally
by everyone um before everything started
happening that something just wasn't
right that morning
um so i i was feeling that and uh the
day transpired how it transpired and
you know my my birthdays ever since have
not been the same you know the first few
years were very very hard i even made
the mistake of spending one of those
years in new york city for my birthday
um and
that was a very very dreary day
needless to say
um but
you know
i just make it a point to
especially these days i just kind of
have to just stay away from the media
um
you know i i
stay away from the news things like that
i mean of course i keep an ear out to
what's going on because
uh there's also just a slight paranoia
that something can happen again on that
day right um and that i've come to find
over the years that a lot of people that
share my birthday we
deal with a lot of this
minor ptsd that we experienced on that
day
um
and that we got from from that day and
with that being our birthday so
um i wouldn't say it changed how i
approach
um
but
it it did make me appreciate
why i love airplanes and why i love
aviation
because
for a while a lot of people didn't want
to fly anymore
myself included but i really had to
rekindle that within myself
and
you know
allow that love for aviation to
you know
continue on even through all of that
so that that's the best way i can answer
that question um but it it even 20 years
later um don't do the math
20 years later um
you know it's still
it's a lot better these days but you
know there's still a flight
um
you know just and i i feel like everyone
feels it you know it's not just
um people that have birthdays but i feel
for those of us that do have a birthday
on this day it's it's a little
a little heavy for us as well and in a
different kind of way because it's there
have been some times where i felt bad
for celebrating but i'm like this is my
day you know it's it's the day i was
born and i i should be able to celebrate
it the 15 years prior to that everything
was great right so
i've made it a point to continue that on
for the rest of my life
i hope that answers your question yeah
it's a beautiful approach to it um
yeah it was my
my parents anniversary but they got
divorced uh before it happened
uh it has a it has a dual a dual
significance in some ways for them but
yeah you know when i think about um
airplanes which i associate with joy
liberation with freedom and then being
used as weapons
of course with the innocent souls that
we lost um you know it's it's it still
hurts me i was much older actually i was
flying to chicago on that day from l.a
and uh obviously everything got
cancelled but it was a it was a truly
truly you know sea change
in my viewpoint of the world and um you
know i i can't
uh truly appreciate the significance of
having a birthday on that day but um but
i do want to uh you know obviously uh
certainly wish you a happy birthday
we'll conclude with that later on but
before we do that i want to talk about
uh some of my other favorite poems that
revolve around physics so i mean you and
i are kindred spirits like i said
physics you're a poet i love poetry and
um and and and you're a pilot and i want
to get in the physics uh domain of your
uh ten dimension ten dimensional uh
personality so there's two poems that i
love uh they're in succession there is
um
uh you know kind of always throughout
the book there is uh issues of race do
uh do appear and obviously that is
something uh that we should we should
touch upon uh but i want to ask you
about to read your these two poems black
energy and black matter um those are
those are so
you know joy it's almost like an
equation and some of the ee cummings
like layout i don't know if if you if
you did all the layout and everything
but it kind of reminded me of like the
way when you look at einstein's
equations the structure
of the equations tells you how to do the
math and in your poetry the structure of
the verses
is evocative and i think i think it's
beautiful but anyway uh for readers that
don't have it or listen zone don't have
it would you do me the honor of reading
those two uh black man or black energy
yes um first i want to give a little
background for those two pieces
uh because
we we're talking about race a little bit
here and
i do want to say that
um
those poems were inspired by
the experience of
being a black woman
right
so i wrote the poems as a
using the concept of dark energy and
dark matter as a metaphor
for the life experience of
a black woman such as myself
so
without further ado i'll just get into
them
the first one is called black energy
68 of the universe
she rises
overcoming gravity
accelerating expansion of the cosmos
unsure of how she operates
unsure of what it all means
she outlines the emptiness of space
weak and strong forces of nature
carrying electromagnetic shields
as more space emerges
so does dark energy
and she dominates
and this next piece
along those same lines is called
black matter
27 of the universe
80 percent of its matter
light from her stars not yet arriving to
earth
dark and seen but unseen
unnoticed unacknowledged unobservable
yet she holds the elements of the
universe together
groups of objects function together
through her explanations
she rotates galaxies filling them with
her mass where her stars orbit faster
holes in black serve
as gravity lenses and then light
not normal matter not anti-matter
she is dark matter
the invisible hand of the big bang
those are those two pieces
um i can't help but escape the notion
that you
uh use the the the feminine um
talk about what what is that um how is
it in in in this you know kind of
universe associated with with a female
um that resonates throughout the book um
talk about that and and also this notion
that you know the word cosmos you know i
always put out cosmos and cosmetology
they have the same root and that's like
beauty
and then verse is like verse and it's
like the word spoken by god or whoever
you want the multiverse alan guth
andre linde um talk about the feminine
in the universe and and and this notion
of of blackness and and what does that
mean my friend stefan's book uh you know
is called an outsider's guide
how do you react to that
i mean that's a very layered question i
mean
i
simply
talk about my experiences through
race and
the universe uh through the lens of the
feminine
uh because it reflects on my life
experiences
and it is a way for me to
i guess maybe
approach it in a therapeutic sense
um
and i i think my poem uh which i want to
read uh when we're wrapping up here dark
matters
uh definitely reflects on that as well
and
i have a spiritual relationship with the
universe as well
um
and i don't feel that
science acknowledges
spirituality in the sense that it should
and
i truly believe that balance exists
everywhere
and that parallels exist everywhere and
there are many many parallels between
science and spirituality
so my spiritual approach to seeing the
universe through a feminine lens
is also reflected
in me explaining it in a scientific
sense through my poetry
and that's the best way that i can
answer that question
but
then we'd have to
dig into what is this concept of spirit
science right and
uh the the debate of whether or not
spirituality is relevant to science to
me it is you know but i totally respect
people that think it isn't
and it's the same approach that i have
with philosophy which i feel is the
godfather of science but even today as
much as i appreciate philosophy i don't
feel that
science appreciates philosophy at least
like it used to
um
so these are things that i dance around
and my art creating these parallels
creating these bridges seeing these
things in balance and creating this
balance through my artwork
yeah it definitely does i mean we're
we're always perceiving things you know
as you know looking through the
atmosphere looking through the universe
it's seeing it through a dark
a dark vision or obscured
but our job as scientists especially in
my field experimental scientist is to
design
the perceptions that you can use to
overcome your biases to overcome and see
things as i say you know sensors and
sensibility not just the pure sense not
just the pure sensitivity maybe not just
the pure
materialism there has to be some notion
that we are human beings and some
believe we are endowed by by a creator
some force some spirits some don't some
find that in anthem at the science
um i i think that uh
i agree if you if you had a more
um kind of balanced exposure to
philosophy you'd see it's the root
grounding of all signs philosophy and
mathematics and i i just think that
that's uh truly resonates with me as
well
i want to ask you to read um you know
maybe one more of your favorite poems
help us deconstruct it maybe with a
physics poet kind of take like how to
inculcate a notion of of affection for
poetry uh and some of our colleagues who
may not be you know might be a little
more reluctant to
to drop that stoic analytic sense can
you take one of your poems and walk us
through it and and see how we can do it
analytically not to deconstruct it for
deconstruction sake but what do you
think about when you're constructing
such a thing
um
okay
what comes to mind is a short poem i
wrote titled space time
and
this poem
incorporates
everything that we just talked about
right um a little bit of metaphysics a
little bit of philosophy
uh
some physics um and also love
right and the the
spiritual
uh
association
through love that i that i have
and
i'll just read it and then we can kind
of
deconstruct it a bit
it's very short it just goes
you say anything is possible
but you need space and time
given the space and time
we will transcend space and time
traveling at speeds faster than light
immeasurable to man in his physics
for you and i have no space or time
for impossibilities
and that's that piece
so walk us through how what is the
cosmic genesis of that what does it mean
to you how should we approach it and uh
think about it is it is it multi-layered
as it sounds or is it more kind of um
could be understood in many levels or is
it more properly understood in a
superficial way
it's uh for me it's very multi-layered
um
when i'm in love i feel that that
transcends space and time right
um
the the act of being in love
um is is quote unquote godly right
so when i think of
this godly experience of being in love i
think of the universe and the
experiences
that it gives us and what we understand
about it and that goes way back to
einstein
with his
uh
approach to space time and understanding
of space time
so i play on that a little bit in the
physics sense but i also throw that
metaphysical spiritual sense in there as
well like hey given that space and time
we will transcend space and time
traveling at traveling at speeds faster
than light immeasurable to men in his
physics
because we technically can't travel
faster than the speed of light at least
not yet
right
and
so i play on that as well like with love
this is possible
right this is something that we can do
we don't have space or time for
impossibilities in this space time
so
that's where i'm going with that
because you know as it said and this is
why i'm kind of
more optimistic about artificial
intelligence and i think and people say
oh it's going to take over everything i
say well einstein used to do what are
called gdunkin experiments as you know
thought experiments
and these thought experiments were ways
to approach a reality that he couldn't
access like what if i raced alongside a
light beam
or what he called the happiest thought
of his life was when he realized if i
was falling through space i couldn't
distinguish that from being you know a
free fall from zero uh g acceleration
and uh and the weak equivalence
principle and because of that he called
that the happiest thought of his life
now i can't imagine a computer a knowing
what freefall is like and b knowing like
what's what's happiness for a computer
and i think physics and poetry will
always be things
that only a human mind and a soul
perhaps as you have can illuminate and
uh and i think that's that is um part of
what it means to be a complete human
being i see you as a renaissance mind as
a scholar and and that you can approach
things with courage i think that is the
fundamental trait you overcome your fear
of flying you overcome you know these
obstacles in your path as a youngster
going to now going to graduate school
i want to just close with that what do
you look forward to most about graduate
school obviously you know you're you're
just starting out don't know exactly
where your world lines going to go um
you know and most people change their
minds a couple times even in graduate
school what are you most hoping big
picture to to emerge whenever you emerge
with whatever um you know degree
sub-specialty you get what are you
hoping most to achieve
well
for one i am first generation
so i come from a very large family and i
am the youngest
and i am the second to complete a
bachelor's degree
um the first to complete a degree in
stem
and also the first to be pursuing a phd
so
there's a lot of pressure right
um but it's also very very
beautiful um and it it's something to
look forward to because i feel like i'm
carrying the torch for my family
uh for my ancestor for the generations
that i come from and the ones that will
come after me
um
and
i'm i'm very grateful for that feeling
uh because like i was saying earlier i
never thought
grad school was not even in my
considerations right um
let alone finishing an undergrad degree
in in engineering physics at that um
so
i mean even just thinking about it now
because it's still fresh i graduated in
may and it's still very surreal to me
that i actually completed that
i look forward to more of that feeling
just going further
because i can and in a sense i'm
supposed to
because this isn't just about me this is
pushing forward for
you know
those before me that did not have these
opportunities
and
you know
understanding that i am their wildest
dreams
right
so in that sense i'm greatly looking
forward to grad school
um
in another sense
i look forward to
giving back
because
like i i danced around this a little
earlier but i i was not the greatest
student
growing up i'm just being honest um i
was not good at math i was not good at
science um
you know i struggled with these subjects
immensely right um
to the point that i thought
you know going to school for physics i
mean who am i kidding you know i would
talk myself out of it then there's that
impostor syndrome that we spoke about
right um which i still struggle with to
this day
and
i think about everything that i'm going
through and what i'm accomplishing and
the obstacles that i've overcome
and i think about kids
that are back home in chicago going to
these schools that are
uh you know
under funded
they don't have proper resources um you
know these are the kind of schools that
i went to and
i want to give back in the sense of
finding those kids like me who don't
think that they are any good at physics
and math or
any stem subjects who may have interests
and fascinations in these subjects right
um be it by way of anime or comic books
or whatever because you get that a lot
but then there's like a hard stop with
them pursuing it at an academic or
professional level and i just want to be
there to
um do what i can to show them that they
can
right
i would love to teach math i would love
to teach physics in inner city high
schools inner city middle schools i
would love to start stem programs that
use the arts or the expressive arts as
pedagogy to teach some of these subjects
which i think will catapult the interest
in these subjects as well
such as using hip hop as pedagogy to
teach physics uh for instance and that's
something i'm building on that's
something i i look to
do more research on um in grad school
and
so i mean
those are the main two things like just
just carrying the torch
knowing that i've been past the torch
and i'm i'm moving forward
and also
not getting so far ahead that i can't
turn around and you know give back and
understand that i'm blazing these trails
for many to come after me in the same
way that those before me blaze trails to
give me the opportunity to even do this
so i'm grateful
ah that's so uh so and delightfully here
reminds me of um
famous physicist uh jacob zeldovich who
was in the soviet union a jew he was
oppressed and and struggled but he
communicated to his student alexander
palmerev who became my mentor he said
the word scientist in russian
means someone who was taught
and that's a translation and to me that
evokes
an obligation that we have a scientist
to repay you know pay it back but also
pay it forwards and i'm just so
delighted that you exist joanne
because um you really are this you know
when i when i first heard you and you
read this this one of your poems last
year on the closing ceremony for the
simon's msbp
program um you know i was just like
riveted uh i got my kids all to shut up
for
a couple minutes while you read it so i
could give it the attention it deserved
and there's so many poems in this book
that are
they're heart-wrenching i mean you got
to have you know a box a box of uh a
kleenex nearby when you talk about you
know quantum mechanics love mechanics
there's heart-wrenching stuff in here
there's deep stuff there's fun stuff
there's you know i don't call it
frivolous but it's delightful and i just
want to thank you for this book i want
to thank you for for your mind and your
contributions
and that i have no doubt you're going to
be a supernova in this field and
whatever you do and i hope you'll stay
in touch and come back on whenever you
have a new project or something that you
want to share with the universe because
um you're the reason in a large way
you're the reason that i started this
this mission that i'm on to connect
the multiverse's greatest minds and
people that inspire me so i want to
thank you for inspiring me i want to
wish you uh join a very very special
birthday i'm not going to say what it is
i can't do the math in real time but i
want to wish you a special birthday
september 11th now i will say it has it
has at least one very positive
connotation absolutely
thank you and i would love to close with
a poem if we have time for that
uh because we were talking earlier about
uh why i named the book continuum and i
was kind of thinking of
about that a little more throughout the
interview um
because i
we understand a continuum to be
defined as something that
keeps going and changing over time right
um
and that explains my poetry
that explains me that explains you that
explains life existence that explains
the universe
um
and in that sense i think
uh this this poem that i wrote
is a a very liberating and healing piece
for us especially in these times
and when we met last year
via the nsbp program with simon's
observatory at princeton
um
i was a part of a very
very interesting intriguing beautiful
research that i was just having a great
time being a part of but we all know
that outside of our doors there were
some very very
uh
energetic chaotic things happening in
the world
so
this piece is bittersweet because i
wrote it in that sense of
why i love astronomy
why i love astrophysics
why i love the universe why i love space
because it gives me perspective about
our experiences here
on earth and as human beings sharing
this life experience on this planet
and
i think that we get so lost and so
uh
divided at times just by our our little
differences you know
i think i read somewhere uh correct me
if i'm wrong i'm not sure how true this
is but
we're 99 the same
yeah oh more yeah
we're 99 the same that's right
we're so divided
by those that that one percent of
differences that we have
um so
dark matters
uh brings in that spirituality brings in
that philosophy brings in that
metaphysics brings in that science and
also brings in that that art of
everything that makes me me and why i
love this work so without further ado
i'll get into this piece
at the event horizon of a black hole
there's been a rising of black souls
we arrived in time capsules
we are the masterminds
ford fast rewind viewing stars from past
design
we are the last to shine
a mysterious class divine
these dark matters have beginnings
in the origins of originality
we are just now earning our winnings but
we were here before the galaxies
an argument full of fallacy but what you
believe becomes reality
and what's in us is in the stars so i
view our history through this analogy
all that is old is new and all that is
new is old
our son has told the truth
reflecting seas like blue to gold
we are neglected as a collective yet we
possess these star qualities
i'm so invested in this perspective
earthed at center like ptolemy
with silent big bangs preferred
like when the big bang occurred
these are times of civil unrest where
now big bangs are heard
from that of the celestial sphere we are
the extraterrestrials here
we arrived from frozen suns blaze
resilient the chosen ones
among wildfires burning slow we're
enduring constant struggle
turning whole via wormholes
we expand like constant hubble
we are infinite yet finite
bringers of dawn in twilight
sparking bright like pyrite
we were alive when we arrived
a monolith of afterthoughts
but we're layered like earth's core
take off explore like astronauts
we are truly before before
without our dark energy
the universe would collapse unto itself
we are the entities of that chemistry
bodies holding place like the kuiper
belt
the distinction between you and i
remains to be a false dichotomy
for at the heart of pirates life
lies a sacred and beautiful geometry
through devastation comes celebration
for our true wealth lies in astronomy
yet many beings look down at night
aligned with man's unbroken economy
a virus claiming its older victims
i must look to the sky for solace
for we are all of the solar system we
are earthly flawed yet cosmically
flawless
are we nearing our 11th hour
will we fold under this pressure
with nature fueling our powers we can
change the world like that of tesla
make a life but one can take it
bullets fly but we're the matrix this is
scientific but also sacred as no one
ever truly dies
through portals we become immortal
i know now what my calling is
i look to the stars for reminders we're
survivors and we come from something so
much greater than all of this
that's that piece
i love it it's uh it's touching it's
moving it's inspiring and it's also mind
expanding
i i like to think of you as
an experimentalist in any way and a
duncan experiment a thought
experimentalist
of the highest caliber and joanne
paradigm thank you i want to thank you
so much for for being who you are and i
hope someday we can fly together and i
hope someday we can do some poetry slams
together and i hope we can do some
physics together uh you're so glad
you're in the university of california
system we didn't lose you back to those
illinois folks again or whatever
i hope we can have many strong
interactions in the future thank you so
much and happy happy birthday joanne and
please go to my website uh
www.meatparadigm.com
for more information on everything that
i do if you're interested in my book you
can purchase it there you can read more
of my poetry you can hear some of my
music and
just see what i'm up to and my links to
my social media accounts are also on my
website and i just want to say that if
you fly with me brian got to make sure
you got a strong stomach
i like to have fun
i don't know it could be a smooth
landing who knows i'll have links to all
your stuff in the in the show notes and
in the text box and youtube and
again once again thank you for sharing
uh this slice of
the space time continuum with me and my
listeners
and happy birthday to you as well thank
you for having me thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]